foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
welcome to the show look at the lovely
faces my man MB is in the middle uh
actually let me do it right let me do it
right my name is Greg Ivory this is a
new year welcome I mean Happy New Year
to you guys uh welcome to everybody
that's coming to the show my name is
Greg Ivory next to me is the man I like
to call MB you might know him as Michael
Boland and next to him is the man we
like to call around here producer Ryan
hey how are we how we doing fellas we we
good
good man things are good New Year same
energy got my lucky betting shirt on
it's on this side okay okay right
Ryan's being quiet Ryan's been quiet
usually Ryan's a chirp her but he's been
quiet pretty you know before the show
Ryan how are we feeling today are we
going to win no I'm feeling confident I
I will say I thought the new year I was
gonna get the man of the people from you
Greg but it's it's not I'm gonna have to
work towards that you bro I'm giving you
your Kudos you are amen you're you're
amen of the people like it's not up to
me to decide if you're a man it's up to
the people so the people you know what
I'm saying yeah yeah yeah yeah well hey
well you guys know why we're here the
people know why we're here it is time to
cook up another NBA five leg parlay drop
your Best Bets for tonight
in the chat drop them in the chat use
those chat fingers uh we're talking TNT
games only today we're talking TNT games
only Ryan
I said it you've been quiet
that gonna change right now I mean what
are the people talking about it is gonna
change so just a reminder the two games
that are on TNT are the Boston Celtics
and the Dallas Mavericks and oh we got
it right up there the Los Angeles
Clippers and the Denver Nuggets so
let me just wait let me just say yeah to
start 2023 this is about a good a double
header as you can have on TNT yes a lot
of star power tonight so we just gotta
get the right picks so we can start this
year off right yeah uh definitely got to
get the right picks to start this year
off right Ryan what should we go we're
talking about yeah let's do it oh and
awk dropped three but I'm only gonna I'm
only gonna accept one of them so he said
Tatum over 31 and a half points Luca
over 34 and a half points Jalen Brown
over 28 and a half points I think his
line is 26 and a half points there's a
lot of points can I guess which one you
like
so you say before the show I'm quiet I
tell you exactly why I'm quiet because
this guy always outs me for the picks
that I have before the show so you go
ahead tell them tell them what I'm gonna
say
he likes Jason Tatum over 30 points I
love it that's what he likes
that was interesting you were calling
this a what I was calling this a Jason
Tatum Legacy game that for most people
that means 40 plus points for me it's
just taking the point below what is but
his point total actually is
we're teasing teasing it down this
sounds like a New Year's resolution like
you're crying out for help like
this is your this is your cry for help
you don't want to be too bold anymore
you just want to win yeah uh so I like
this for two reasons he's coming off a
bad game uh the Mavericks don't play any
defense and I had two of our producers
uh Asian Abby jump in my ear and say
they love Jason Tatum tonight so I feel
like that's enough love for Jason Tatum
for me to be and the reason behind it so
wait so it's absolutely I didn't know I
didn't know that you were gonna make
that your reasoning so that's the reason
that you're rocking with Jason Tatum
over 30. I had two people so I had two
people support it I had two oh hold on I
had two people supported he's coming off
a bad game and the Mavericks still play
any defense what those were three
reasons but the supporters like nah okay
okay now I'ma leave it alone I'm Gonna
Leave a Vibes Vibes Good Vibes videos
all right Jason Tatum 30 points I mean I
don't dislike it he's been balling this
year MB if you have a take on it
I agree I mean I watched that last game
uh because I had money on it uh and he
did play pretty bad I will say though
Jalen Brown has picked up a lot of slack
when he's had his bad games and I see a
pick in here Jalen Brown over three
threes that might be a little easier to
get he's got a lot of volume in terms of
the amount of Threes that he shoots but
like I like Ryan said I think this is
gonna be a high scoring game Dallas
plays no defense so either way if that's
one of our first picks I'd be happy with
it we can wait we can talk about both
yeah like I'm okay adding if we want to
add Jason Tatum in here oh by the way
the other note that I was given about
Jason Tatum said he's gonna score 80
tonight we unfortunately cannot we we
can't bet that so that's funny even if I
yeah unfortunately there's we're not
going to get enough value because I
think you can only go up to 40. yeah I
would like to know what the number is to
score 80 points that'd be pretty
interesting number yes
um all right Jalen Brown Jalen Brown's
number is is two is at two and a half
you know what we do here when somebody
gives us an over we just knock it down a
pug we just drop it down just a little
bit yeah not too much
okay minus 350. that's a good leg to
start there we go yeah I don't hate that
I like it I think we're at a good place
to start
we're in a good spot I mean the waves
look in the Celtics Celtics are going to
win this game the way we're betting it
uh yeah we'll see we'll see
okay I see wayne 60 saying Kawhi over 23
and a half
okay this is my I have go ahead I have a
beef with this and I know Ryan you're
gonna say the same thing basically that
I am I cannot bet anything on Kawhi
Leonard because some days he plays 29
minutes some days he plays 16 minutes
some days he just like is on the not on
the injury report doesn't play so I
think it's too random and I think this
is gonna be a really tight game
I don't know if I can go with Kawhi
Leonard man
Kawhi is banned uh the last time we bet
Kauai uh we bet him 20 plus points when
he was going back to Toronto and scored
15. wait wait what was yeah
oh my God that was good I love the
energy Brian you bring a dance you bring
a Tick-Tock dances to the show yeah
there you go I was being accused of
being too quiet I wasn't ready for the
for the first show of the new year I'm
back we're all back
Brian's back baby he is back
shout out to my man Ryan being back all
right man but all right so we got two we
got two locked in
we're feeling good about this the
audience is feeling good or I mean are
they do we yeah I feel good yeah I mean
yeah we're not getting any we're not
we're not getting any negative reaction
we're just getting more we're getting
more takes which is exactly what we need
that's what we need exactly yeah Wayne
60 said Jamal Murray over 23 and a half
points at assists why not
yeah this this is a this is a prop that
is gonna obviously be driven by the
points that he has to score I'm not too
worried about him getting to 15 or 16
maybe even 20 but I do worry that if
Kawhi and Paul I don't know if Paul
George is in or out but if he's in they
got some good Wing Defenders that might
make this one a little tough
we can go to it
um
yeah let's let's go to it we're getting
some Luca takes but we can go we can go
back and forth
uh so I'm seeing I'm seeing some more
keep keep going Ryan I'm seeing some
more just want to call them out would uh
wood 20 plus points I saw that money
that's interesting in a game that we
think is going to feature a lot of
points uh
uh bk37 shout out BK Steven Adams over
two assists
that's not in the TNT game but I do like
that pick and I think I'm gonna dabble
in the other parlays that I make tonight
but shout out to BK glad he's in here
how can Ryan be back he never left I
totally agree
also uh Dominic
Cruz Dominic Cruz is in the common sense
Grant Williams over rebounds oh okay I
have a take on this I bet on okay
Williams
uh might have either been last night or
whenever they played the Thunder I think
it was it was two nights ago maybe uh
dude sold I mean sold they played really
bad he played he got a yeah atrocious
the other thing about Grant Williams
like I think he's a I think he's a solid
player he also is just like
his minutes aren't very reliable so you
need him to get this in like a short
amount of time which adds so much
pressure like when you're talking about
rotation players it is kind of a toss-up
but I don't hate the I don't hate the
idea of the play but if Ryan says that
he's sold I'm not trying to have that
bad vibes yeah no I agree and that's
Ryan's team so like you know what I mean
yeah I also like am of the opinion that
we maybe shouldn't go to Celtic heavy
like I think we've got the Tatum and
brown and I feel pretty good about that
I I feel like it would be wrong to not
include Luca in some sort of way in this
parlay oh absolutely
yeah Lucas points I think I think it's
probably close to even money for him to
score 30. I was looking early but like
he's but he's been getting I mean I
think he went on a run where he had over
35 and like seven straight games so it
doesn't tip it doesn't totally scare me
but that guy does it all you know he he
can pass he can rebound so if we want to
get Luca in there I think that there's
some ways to do it Wayne 60 says Luca
over eight and a half assists
that's interesting I like that too
somebody dropped him to get a triple
double
so like I I like the assists
and his assists are at what eight and a
half so what are we looking at eight if
we did eight assists
I think we can only do eight or we can't
even do it yeah eight or six
that puts us to two to one
I don't hate that at all yeah and then
we're two we're two legs away from
yeah from Victory from
we did get some comments about the
Christian Wood thing yeah
I don't know man that guy can ball it's
just 20 plus is a lot 20 is a lot
definitely for him I definitely feel a
little more comfortable with the eight
assists
um so I think we keep I think we keep no
we keep really good one yeah I think I
saw one from B Thompson that I thought I
really liked oh he was saying Joker over
uh yeah
yeah I saw that too let's head over
this is this is one that I love not only
because Joker is one of my favorite
players but he just he's just so fun to
watch and when you think about him
rebounding that's like one of the things
that's like a lock for him people got to
make shots he's at 11 and a half that's
beautiful
I'm surprised you're not doing what we
normally do
like let's just remember it's at 467 so
let's see if we if we knock it down to
10 where are we at
306. I mean it's up to we can see where
we're at after the fifth leg but I kind
of like it at over 11 and a half I won't
lie I think we're gonna have to do one
regular over under to get this where
where are we and this should be the one
and this should be the one well it's a
pen I I guess that's what I'm saying
like we could always go back to this and
and see where we're at
um but I wouldn't mind if we have to
yeah if we have to rewind this I
wouldn't mind doing the normal I got a
question if you think he's gonna go over
11 and a half yeah
12 plus yeah what's the 12 plus looking
like
oh it's yeah it's what the 11 and a half
would have been okay so the same thing
yeah okay all right so I see a really
good cap in here Philip Marquez shout
out to you Derek white over three
assists
is minus 150 two assists is minus 345
the last five games he put it in here
six three four three five
oh so that we're taking three
um
it feels like that's a good number I
know we have three picks from that from
that uh
[Music]
and obviously like
yeah it's only two games so if we're
heavy on one yeah my opinion there's
nothing wrong with
it it would be kind of fun to just like
sweat Joe catch rebounds in the last
game and not have to sweat anything else
right
that would be kind of fun we're just
like missing we're just praying for Mrs
repeatedly from the Clippers which they
can do well we took yeah we took 10 plus
rebounds so all right here's my here's
my take I'm trying to trying to get this
going a little bit what if we take jokic
over 11 and a half rebounds or 12 plus
however we want to put it and we tease
Luca assist down to six
that feels like a good play ask the chat
I mean we got to find out what the chat
thinks of this parlay anyway so yeah so
chat that's that's my suggestion we keep
Tatum 30 plus we keep Jalen two plus
threes we keep Derek white over two and
a half assists
and then we change jokic from 10 plus
rebounds to over 11 and a half and tease
Luca down to six plus assists
also shout at me for not one time
messing up uh yo it's just last name
this is a first for me this guy's been
haunting me the past few weeks on this
show
hey Ryan I got a question though
I got a question bro what what's up why
are we dropping down Luca Ashish numbers
we like what's the what's the reasoning
like I know you're a math guy and I know
you like to make things make sense yeah
so like what's the reason okay uh first
of all that was sarcasm I'm not a math
guy very anti-mass I hate it uh I just
think it's more likely well Jalen brown
two plus three is my opinion that is the
luckiest play we have in here we put
that we could put that to the side I
just really think Jason Tatum goes off
tonight and the one thing that's closest
to the actual line that we have is Dodge
itch we so we have med8 plus and his
line is at eight
or at eight and a half I'm sorry so I
think if we tease that down the number
isn't won't be crazy
you're trying to be you're trying to be
a man the man of the people you're
trying to be the man of people and we'll
be mad at the people go away
once you look uh they're not really
liking the idea go look at the comments
I I do think though the comment about uh
the eight is is spot on because to me
Luca I mean he might score 50 but in the
event that he doesn't a lot of the
people around him are gonna have to
contribute and like I keep saying like
we think this is going to be high
scoring yeah they are I think he gets to
that eight pretty easily all right in
order for the south I mean in order for
the Mavericks to compete in this game I
think people are going to have to help
Luca out on the offensive end he knows
that Jason Kidd knows that the Celtics
even know that so
I I like the assist I'm with the I'm
with the chat I think he gets eight easy
okay so then what do we think about
moving which I already did here so this
is me this is me taking control uh what
do we think about moving uh Jason Tatum
down to 25 plus points
and that leaves us at plus 416. that is
without me adjusting uh yokich's rebound
above so right now again we have Jalen
brown two plus made threes Dodge a plus
assist which the that's the chat slag
that's the the chat saying Ryan leave
that alone uh Derek white over two and a
half assists Jason Tatum 25 plus points
and then jokic 10 plus rebounds but
again if we're moving down Jason Tatum
to 25 I would say move yokich up to 12
plus rebounds all right let's see what
it does all right
yeah I like yoga but Ryan why are we
where is this coming from is this is the
people well I just tease it I'm taking
what the people have given me and then
making it to Ryan's parlays so all right
so Dalton in the control room change
chats parlay to Ryan's parley because
that's basically what he's trying to do
here that's not the people the people
helped pick these picks and you're
sitting here trying to manipulate the
numbers manipulate the picks and now
we're at plus 416 when you the guy that
don't want to bet under plus 600 a five
leg parlay doesn't go under 600 or
something like that you said a couple
weeks ago where where is the where's the
propaganda here coming from where is
this slander the slander's coming from
I'm gonna sue you for libel after this
you said that
Ryan I feel like I'm always the middle
person in this but like remain relaxing
kind of you are acting kind of out of
pocket today
see what is going on what is going on
first stop too quiet now I'm out of
pocket there's nothing that's out of
pocket the chat is giving me their picks
what I'm doing it's actually firing on
you because Darian said after last week
I trust Ryan and he's laughing I can't
tell if he's being for real or not I
think he's being for real there's a lot
of exclamation points a lot of laughing
emojis
I don't know
I I prefer to look at it in the positive
way look it this is what I'm trying to
say I what I don't want is I don't want
to come in here next week and then the
chat gave us a pic and then I'm sitting
here with my feet kicked up saying we
lost because of the chat that's not what
I want I want to chat I want the chat to
be like over 31.5 points for Jason Tatum
and then Ryan teased it down to 25 plus
and we all get rich I love that like the
chat has become like a really open and
honest Community because darian85 was in
favor of you Ryan but we got zivi 326
who's saying quotations man of the
people so are we ignoring that Darian
came back in here and said leave Ryan
alone he came through the clutch last
week yeah
yeah son he's on your side yeah I've got
numbers you got something yeah that like
I said you are a man of the people y'all
don't know about the men but right
honestly in all honesty in all honesty
like jokes aside I like what you did
here we're at plus 621 and what you did
did boost us up yes yes sir I mean this
again this is what I do they call me the
numbers guy the man of the people the
numbers guy uh everything you just said
you don't like math how are you the
numbers guy that don't I may not like I
may not like it but I just manipulated
the numbers and now look at us now look
at the odds on this thing it's beautiful
it is okay so I don't know let's let's
get back into the chat because we have
some takes they don't like Derek White
Mike Ritter doesn't like Derek white
he's saying Jamal Murray but he's not
giving us a play so I he should know
what this show is about but I mean if we
want to take out
if we want to take it out
tell them if you want to take it out
give us give me something exactly that's
it
I'm not asking for much yeah Richard
Richard baynard said Jamal Murray over
white but again what are we What
specifically
but Greg also you read the numbers for
Derek white or no I which was a bolt no
bowling I'm sorry bowling you read the
numbers see there you go
it was a good handicap
oh I'm not saying it's a bad handicap
but if the people want to take it out
this isn't my parlay of stairs I I just
think we can get more lucky like I
really do think we can like
you know buy some down yeah come on Ryan
do what you do like you are the
analytics guy yeah now the numbers now
on the numbers guys
all right uh how low can we buy assist
down oh two plus assists I mean if we
can get Derek white hold on
let's see let's leave Derek white in the
past and let's move on to something yeah
okay so then I so then this is my
suggestion it's like do we want
something from the later game
I did like bowling's take of like if we
get through this early game all we got
to do is root for jokic boards which
could be fun
that definitely can't be fine BK BK
jumped in with a good uh note he said
we're walking a fine line with 12 boards
against the team with multiple good
rebounders
so that just means whatever that's the
same thing is going over 11 and a half
though like but right I get what you're
saying Greg but what I think this is a
crossroads right if we take something
that's a little more controversial
better odds
then we can drop him down to 10 and then
it feels more lucky there's a lot of
plays people really want to people
people really want to look at this
Christian Wood number I don't think 20
is okay I think 20 is probably too much
but I think there's some plays out here
to kind of boost this up hey my boy B
Thompson said bro take Marcus Smart to
steals it's Marcus Marcus Smart's not
playing tonight I don't think yeah yeah
like I just thought it was funny that he
said do you even bet on steals I think I
think is there a can you bet on still
seriously I I don't know I I I yeah
that's a
not my expertise
uh Wayne six that said next week Ryan
I'll tell you about Jamal Murray tell me
about Jamal Murray now like he they've
been telling you Ryan you just focused
on Derek white all right so then what do
we okay so then all hold the phone let's
do it everybody hold on everybody hold
on let's
let I'm gonna go back to a play that was
heard earlier so I forget the username
that dropped it so when I say this call
yourself out so this isn't like a oh
this is a Ryan play this is Ryan cooking
up Ryan's parlay that's not what's
happening here you're right but it's not
so we're I'm gonna tease jokic back down
to 10 boards because that's what I do
that works
and we go to player Combos and it was a
take that was dropped earlier
Jamal Murray 20 yep yep over 23 and a
half points and assists
now why can't we do that ah because it's
okay so let's look at his let's look at
his points all right
all right
shout out Wayne 60. that's who it was it
was Wayne 60. and I just found out that
we're not allowed because you can't put
a player combo in the same game parlay
17 and a half points
is Jalen Brown number I'm sorry I don't
I don't mean to throw a card wall here
let's do what you're talking about Ryan
I'm sorry always Greg I'm always sitting
off speed so you can throw whatever
you'd like I'm coming high and in on the
next pitch if you're sitting on speed
bro
all right here we go here we go here we
go all right all right uh uh uh uh you
guys just made me forget what I was
talking about you were gonna say
something about Jalen Brown
oh two two assists is this number really
at two assists
I don't know
I don't think so much
yeah no I somebody in the chat uh wait
can I get can we ask Wayne 60 real quick
because he's the biggest Jamal Murray
guy I think I've ever met in my life do
we do we like what do we like better
Jamal Murray over 17 and a half points
or do we like his assists at over five
and a half
my opinion but yeah let's see what uh
let's see what my man Wayne says and
then we can uh
debate no we can't do 15 plus look at
this
plus 322. well yeah that's because we
only have four left oh is that the fifth
leg bring the opens back up to 12. he's
getting that
um I don't hate it
I don't hate it
I said go look at it you're in the
you're in the pocket you get Jamal
Murray at 15 points you put jokic back
up to 12 and what are the numbers
we don't have to do it I just want to
see
as the numbers guy of the show it gets
us to plus 468. I don't know I you know
me I always like it at least plus 500.
that's what I was talking about that
okay so it's plus 500. that's okay
so why don't we talk more about the
Legacy game of one Jason Tatum and put
him back to 30. okay and B okay because
it's a legacy game Ryan yes it is Ryan
you said it was a legacy game and you
said Legacy game that's over 40 points
yes
okay go ahead no no I was just gonna say
can I can I try something real quick and
don't yell at me when this is gonna look
really gross for a second but if we're
gonna get Jason Tatum back up to 30.
he's at minus 800 right now for 25 plus
so if I tease jokic back down to 10 I
don't want any no yelling all right okay
okay all right
cannot say the chat parlay has to say
Ryan's brother
oh the work you're doing like this needs
to be your parlor
IDE we did all that
go put the 12 boards
let's go put the 12 words 25 points
right or you said 30 MB
30 points for Tatum 12 I'm getting
thumbs up from Ritter Ritter's on board
BK I'll ride with the 12 for the squad
let's go see what the kids he says
bowling gets it that's what they're
saying in the comments Ritter jumped in
late and then started slandering Derek
white so I you know I'm taking his takes
with a grain of salt right now
uh rebounds
all right we're getting it back up let's
see what we need that's gonna be what we
need right here no this is this is good
what's good about this I'm feeling good
like seriously
let's go you want to you want to are we
locking this in are we calling it [ __ ]
let's read it Ryan's Portland
thank you thank you control room this is
definitely Ryan's parlay it's not the
people's it's not the people I listen
just because I'm the man of the people
does it make me the people that's not
how this goes if you were a man of the
people you would respect the people's
decisions right I am I'm the people are
giving us these are all takes from the
chat no these are your takes you're
taking what the people are giving you an
infusing Ryan into it
that's what you're doing quick feedback
on this Danny Danny Marie saying she
likes this one
is saying this is more lucky B Thompson
says I like it
lauriega's saying Mark marketing plus 24
and a half Point that's not in the TNT
game but you might have showed up late
so I'm not gonna go off but this feels
pretty pretty good to me I like it I
like it too bro I'm not gonna lie B
Thompson said Ryan embrace your parlay
it's locky I'm
I'm gonna be I'm gonna be unwell tonight
if we're branding this is Ryan's parlay
okay okay wait wait it's ridiculous let
me let me also just speak from the other
side of the table the last time we gave
Ryan this much power we did win on
Thursday night so did it's literally one
week from today
we did win it was in it it's for granted
but we did win so I like those vibes
kinda this is uh this is probably what I
can get behind I like this
uh hey there I mean I I it seems lucky
the chats rocket with it Ryan's
obviously rocking with it and B has his
lucky betting shirt on so I know he's
rocking with it I guess we're locking
this one in
honestly like we haven't even asked for
thumbs up or thumbs down and we're
getting a lot of goods we're getting so
much good you know Vibes like I think we
just gotta lock this in bro I I agree
and B I was gonna say I didn't want to
cut you off but they gave us the thumbs
up before we could even ask for it a lot
of people were saying this is hot they
liked it this is the one so uh we're
just gonna lock it in Ryan would you do
the honors in reading your parlay for
the people
the people's parlay the people's parlay
but well brands at his mind that's fine
so we've got Jason Tatum Legacy game 30
plus points Jalen brown two plus three
pointers made Luka doncic eight plus
assists jokic 12 plus rebounds Jamal
Murray 15 plus points five legs plus
676. I mean
I mean this is awesome this is great you
said you said 576 you mean I don't know
670s did I say 576 I mean six seven six
six six seven yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I like it man I like it hey if you want
to tell our five leg part leg make sure
you head on over to FanDuel and opt in
to the TNT Thursdays no sweat parlay for
a free bet if it loses
that's bad vibes Ryan did you write this
that's terrible Vibes I didn't know I
didn't know what we were what was gonna
happen in this show sometimes I come in
and it's it's the Greg parlay it's the
chats parlay this is Ryan's parlay today
a producer Max just got in my ears said
he would never write that Brian
if the parlay loses uh fanduel's hooking
you guys up okay but the parlay is not
loose no bad vibes here a lot of gbos
all right let's uh y'all want to grade
some bets and B want to create some best
let's do it
and uh talk to be people uh lauriega
who gave us a bunch of thumbs down which
you know tough because didn't jump in
here with many takes is a replacement
but all good uh Luca triple double
tonight
oh
MB didn't you say you said earlier I
said yeah
yeah I have I have no reason to believe
that he's not gonna put up a triple
double I mean every night he he takes
the court he's liable to give you 30 15
and 10. so in a game that we've said a
lot that it feels like it's gonna be
high scoring if I have to grade this I'm
gonna give this a B plus because the
numbers just I mean he's averaging damn
near triple double the whole season so
why would I bet against that it's at
plus 390 by the way
hey there it is that's not a bad value
either I mean like I think when when
Russ was going on his triple double
barrage that one season it was like down
to plus 200 for a triple double so I
feel like there's like decent value on
that yeah whoa a Haitian Rebel came in
here my bad Ryan I know you're in the
comments but Haitian Rebel came in here
and said add one more lick whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
see Charlie coming here and like uh make
this as far away the last the last time
we've moved it to six it did not go well
let me remind the people that the Greg
leg did in fact come through it did come
on now come on now and be let them know
let the people know
[Laughter]
we've got Ritter jumping in here giving
us golf locks I mean
wrong show man this guy's come in here
and he's slander and Derek while he's
giving us golf locks we we need to be
better uh badhave boy uh Christian Wood
20 plus points he's upset we didn't take
it
listen I think it might hit I guess in a
five leg I mean I might want to bet that
as a Solo solo I was going to say that
in people right here bro no no no heck
no we're right here we're right here
that's a good thing we're flowing Ryan's
over I don't know
right right
propaganda for his personal parlay
tonight this is
all right we love you here bro if you
don't if you don't know we love you here
bro
25 and a half points over 25 and a half
points for Lori Market in tonight not a
TNT game uh well he's been on fire as of
late who are the chats playing tonight
that's a
you got FanDuel yeah I was on the I was
on the Celtics game uh they're playing
the rock yeah I like it I'll give it a
because we're we're going away from the
letters for some reason I'll give it a b
I'll give it a b
yeah the tough thing about being a
Chicago Bulls fan is not only are they
kind of poverty but they only beat teams
that are good we gave away Laurie
marking him for nothing and we do that
we tend to do that with late blooming
athletes so more power to him man he's
having a hell of a season
and I will say a pick that I do like in
here that's Christian Wood related uh
well it is about Christian Wood so it's
not related uh OV L Rose said uh
Christian Wood points and rebounds over
27 and a half that I do like the Celtics
have really been struggling on the board
since Rob Williams has in and out like a
revolving door in the starting lineup uh
so I actually do like that uh a lot if
you're if you're trying to bet on
Christian Wood tonight I think that is
the play over the straight 20 plus it's
plus money though so if you like it then
go for it but shout out to to Darian and
Anthony Marciano I'm assuming I know
darian's from Chicago I'm assuming
Anthony is too he's saying the Bulls are
so aggravating and yes they are I can't
understand this roller coaster so let's
talk about that some other time yeah
maybe we'll get them on a TNT game we'll
be able to you'll be able rumor has it
rumor has it there will be a TNT game in
February featuring the Bulls at home so
if my Chicago homies are down let's all
link up at the United Center but if they
keep playing bad they're gonna Flex that
game out I'm not worried about it uh oh
linking up with MB uh oh uh oh that
sounds like a good time to me that
sounds like a good time to me hey let's
get out of here guys there's some that's
a lot of money to be made it's a lot of
money to be made uh help you at home
hope you go put this parlay in put your
bets in and I hope you win
um
Ryan
sir read the parlay that you stole from
the people one more time that the people
and I worked hand in hand that's how I
that's how I go about it I will say this
right now on the graphic we have the
odds uh plus 676 I'm watching in front
of my face it jumped to plus 693 so
that's good vibes for us but the parlay
is Jason Tatum 30 plus points Jalen
brown two plus uh made threes Luka
doncic eight plus assists yokich 12 plus
rebounds and Jamal Murray 15 plus points
updated
there it is they just updated it in the
control room appreciate you uh my man
Dave boy 99 says I'm tagging you three
fellas when wood drops 20 tonight
look out for me we will be on the look
okay wait a second wait a second I'm
making
I'm making Christian Wood 20 plus points
tonight Squad ride just because we
didn't get it in the parlay it's going
to be available for everyone to see in
the app as soon as this show is over so
your picture shine and you'll get your
moment we're trying to get our first
Squad ride win of this of this new year
so why not start with this there it is
there it is my man MB he does big things
for the app so if you guys don't know
now you know you guys want anything to
do with the app talk to my man and be he
is the plug all right hey let's get out
of here we've been talking
that's a little bit too much not not too
much but this is just a little bit just
Ryan really but it's okay
um
let's get out of here all right hey my
name is Greg Ivy just be next to me is
the man I call MB you might know him as
Michael Bolin if you need anything with
the app tap it with my guy and next to
him is the man we all love
amen of the people
producer
we love you right we we like really love
you Bureau because when we win it's like
you're helping us win because
like your parlay you know
bro I knew you were gonna say that this
is amazing because whenever you do if
you do give him the man of the people
it's gonna be like every celebration
ever
that's not gonna happen I mean
the people the people that will have to
you know make that decision what about
this if this parlay hits It's redeeming
at Ryan's parlay next week it's the amen
of the people no
you trying to make the rules again there
you go that's
oh this is exactly why
[Laughter]
let's get out of here hey we out of here
man y'all go with some money today peace
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]